- I'm Kim Kutz Elliott, and I work
on humanities content at Khan Academy.
So I thought about things
that were really difficult
for me, and one thing that was hard for me
was class discussion, because I went
to this history class and
I swear that every other
person in that class had like
read every history book ever.
And I don't know how they
did it, but I was convinced
that I was an imposter,
I did not belong in this class. (laughs)
Everyone else was just
completely brilliant,
and you know, they would sit around
and discuss these ideas and
they were kind of vicious,
you know, say like oh,
this text book is wrong.
This person has a terrible argument.
And I'd be sitting there thinking
I haven't even read a text book,
like that's a pretty big deal. (laughs)
So I was just, I think
I was just terrified
to open my mouth in this class
and kinda reveal to everyone
that I didn't belong there.
And so I went to a teacher
who was a mentor to me
and I said, everybody's so mean.
I'm not this mean, and
he said to me, you know,
"It's okay to be the person who says,
"what can we learn from this,
"and it's okay to be the person
who wants to take something
"positive away from this class."